[Music]
got down on one knee and gave someone
the key to your apartment and it was a
big moment and everybody was back here
like that was a key to his apartment the
most nerve-wracking moment of my entire
life
you're nerve-racking because you weren't
making it appear to be a proposal or
nerve-wracking good give me the key
all the above the key doesn't really
open anything it's a proverbial key to
my keypad lock for my house but it's
2018 technologies you haven't talking
about how you want to settle down a
little bit more and kind of find a place
to hang your hat does this mean more
time in LA for you I think it might yeah
I have been toying with a few different
places across the country but I think
the West Coast is the Best Coast and
that's what I'm gonna say this is good
Dean like you said you spent some time
in relationships but now I think you
found a really good one oh let's let's
see how long it takes for her to realize
that she's out of my league I hope not
too long
[Music]